first of all uh there's a you have to
know what the definition of introversion
extroversion are
right socially awkward is not i know
socially awkward extroverts
right it's not if you're uncomfortable
it's not social awkwardness that's not
introversion
i like in terms of it's susan kane's
definition it's about energy which is
um an introvert loses energy from social
interaction
an extrovert gains energy from social
interaction so an introvert wakes up in
the morning with five coins
every social interaction they spend a
coin at the end they are depleted
an extrovert wakes up with no coins
every social interaction they get a coin
and by the end they feel rich
like going to a party they gives them
energy go versus going to a party
sucks your energy so then i'm an
introvert right so i'm a big introvert
right and um what i have learned is it's
i have a big personality but i'm still
an introvert so
what i've learned is that it doesn't
matter which one you are the question is
how do you leverage what you got
right and so i go to parties with an
extrovert
right because that way they can do all
the talking and i can just stand there
and just eat the cheese
and that is fantastic by the way you can
always spot me you can always tell
you go to a party with me and you will
see me standing in corners
or or or lingering by the and when
there's a barbecue
i'm always the chef because then i'd
have to talk to anybody right
but but if you notice i've learned to
leverage what i have so it makes me a
much better public speaker
to be an introvert because i don't like
holding court it freaks me out
but i like talking to individuals so
you'll notice when i speak i talk to you
and then i talk to you and then i talk
to you and i give everybody a whole idea
or a whole thought which actually what i
learned
helps me actually connect with an
audience much better but it's because
i'm an
introvert so if you're an introvert of
course you can be a leader it has
nothing to do
some of the best leaders have you ever
heard of jim senegal most people haven't
because he's awkward and shy
he's a phenomenal leader he's the
founder and former ceo of costco
right like there's phenomenal leaders
richard branson
introvert he's really awkward right
um uh like these are phenomenal
phenomenal leaders who are all
introverts
right but the one thing they all have to
have in common whether you're
extroverted or introvert is
undying belief in your cause right it's
the
and the charisma is not how much energy
you have the charisma
is how much you're willing to devote to
that and if it's all of it
you have charisma you have leadership
[Music]
capacity